if I could change the world I would be
the sunlight in your universe you would
think my love was something really good
baby if I could change the world
this kids a lot of a window that's
that's how is this how his kid died you
know how I found that out so I I forgot
you know like when you couldn't what do
you call it high school has been so
[ __ ] long ago but wait before you
graduate you had to do that thing thing
it like when you when you get your
masters you have to do your dissertation
or some [ __ ] yeah or your thesis or some
[ __ ] yeah well there was that version of
that in high school what the [ __ ] was
that [ __ ] called
biography I am asking the wrong person
there was a thing where you had to
present some [ __ ] at the end of high
school so you could graduate did you
have that [ __ ] present at the end or
some [ __ ] right but I I did whatever my
thing was it was like something like
childhood trauma death and trauma or
some [ __ ] like that and then I found out
I forgot why I chose that subject or if
somebody told me that's something they
should do but I found out that Eric
Clapton's kid fell out of a window from
that assignment that I did I think he
was like jumping on a bed and then he
jumped on the bed he fell out the window
I'm not I'm not laughing because it's
funny I thought I am NOT laughing
because it's funny I'm just saying that
I just it's it's it's interesting tears
in heaven that's where I came from I
used to love that song
it was like a little closer to you know
I used to love that so yeah and yeah I
would listen to it just fly until my mom
of course she knows all this because
she's white and my stepmom right yeah
well this is you've recently recently
found out and then now I was listening
to it on the way here now whenever I
hear it I tear up a little bit because
the lyrics are so you are on this
[ __ ] cry fest family dude and you've
been [ __ ] me up the only reason why I
brought you on here so we talked about
that's been a [ __ ] film that we just
saw right now dude so Gina has been
watching the most saddest things I've
ever seen in my life
now mind you like I'm not somebody who's
like super you know my chisme or
whatever like I don't cry about [ __ ] but
this is the first time in a very long
time that I saw a film where I
sob like I sent her I texted her a
picture of my t-shirt because I didn't
even wipe my face on this shirt that was
just from the tears rolling down my
[ __ ] face soaking into my shirt dude
I cried that much in that film what's
that I don't know the name of the film
right now along with the gods along with
the gods
so it was Korea's like second top
grossing film of all time
and the fucked-up thing is so I heard it
from just like a passing conversation
right I went to go pick up my mail at my
friend's shop one of his employees was
weird on my movies as I go you should
watch it alone the gods and the premise
sounded cool the premises it's a Korean
movie when you die you go and you have
to go through nine trials right so each
trial is like deception or if someone
died because of use stuff like that and
if you pass it then you become
reincarnated and with every trial they
tell you the story of this man who's
like going through these trials after I
wrote or I watched China Busan this
[ __ ] is on her [ __ ] trail of tears
dude that's what you are and then the
big guy from trained Busan like I wanted
to see more movies with him so that's
how I got that suggestion so I started
watching it and I was not ready yeah you
were ready I wasn't [ __ ] ready all
right because you didn't even prepare me
at all for that [ __ ] like anything that
has to do like you know what if you
haven't seen this film it you should go
watch it but just to let you know you're
gonna bawl your [ __ ] eyes out like I
genuinely I genuinely didn't expect to
cry that [ __ ] much and you know in
the beginning of the film to like it
made me tear up a little bit I was like
oh it's just not that bad it's pretty
[ __ ] sensitive and it just starts to
make you cry at every trial yeah just
makes you want to cry even more even
more and even more and in the end the ED
done [ __ ] God to me the end got me
super bad dude yo like I'm talking about
if you if you ever mistreated your
[ __ ] mom you need to watch this film
I called my mom right after I told her I
am a piece of [ __ ] cuz I don't [ __ ]
deserve your love there was a line in
this film by the way that [ __ ]
wrecked me man oh you can't I can't I
can't swallow it listen to I can't
spoils it but
it [ __ ] wrecked me super [ __ ] bad
oh whoa watch it on Hulu and then figure
out your life afternoon because I'm
trying to pick up my life right now
channels it was so sad I know what's the
second one the second one's good too but
it didn't it didn't wreck me like the
first one it's very hard to talk yeah I
kind of like Holly it was a continuation
of the first one too I you know so one
of the actors were replaced in in that
film and the second one so you know when
he's going through the trials yeah
there's the two people that are the
prosecutors one of the prosecutors
changed oh is that really no all Koreans
look the same you son of a [ __ ]
though one of the prosecutors changed oh
yeah the older one he was the main
prosecute wasn't the fat one but there
was a chubby prosecutor and then there
was the other guy in the second film
that got changed okay so that that guy
that changed he's going through a little
a me-too thing right now or something oh
yeah I guess like he like sexually
harass somebody say me too in Korean huh
[Laughter]
like you're very proud of your work Oh
sounds a little cute yeah but I heard
he's going through his own me to thing
right now maybe that's why he wasn't in
that film
oh okay so the first one it's going
through a little not dude thing yeah so
that first guy the he that he wasn't in
the second one when I saw him and then
ray told me that he's actually going to
like this whole meet to situation that's
why people be getting cancelled [ __ ]
everywhere get everywhere everywhere
like I can't like I'm almost scared of
it I feel we should it's not the meets
you think it's more like like they're
gonna go back to my past I was four
years old like I like I killed an ant or
something like office [ __ ] you know
that whole like you know what I I do
appreciate a lot of the stuff that's
been coming to light because like a lot
of this stuff that you like we've been
hearing on media is hearsay right so you
know what I hear through the grapevine
it's still hearsay so you know I read a
couple of comments before because we
spoke about this where we said okay
we've heard stone
about the whole meet - thing right oh
why didn't you say something then like
listen here you [ __ ] dick guzzling
[ __ ] like if I said something it was
through somebody else to somebody else
to somebody else so I'm going to go out
and put out a public video about hearsay
how terrible of a person would I be
especially if it was a true exactly an
information like that's very sensitive
so when this started coming to light oh
[ __ ] like because everybody heard about
the Weinstein [ __ ] yes especially if you
were an actor or you were just in any
type of entertainment people always
talked about Harvey Weinstein that way
but there wasn't any tangible evidence
it was always through somebody else
through somebody else so when his whole
che came up we were like oh [ __ ] it's
[ __ ] true look at that dude cancel
culture though I think it's getting a
little wild though it's a little bit too
much now people are getting canceled for
no reason there's people who can change
and it's especially Twitter people are
not giving them a chance to you know I
mean yeah like it's a it's that's what
they did in the past like I'm sorry well
I mean unless it's like terrible [ __ ]
[ __ ] like Weinstein but I'm talking like
little things I think they tried to
cancel um brother nature oh I dare you
first of all we do not touch brother
nature okay I don't know what he really
does for a living I don't know how this
gets balling out so much cuz he's just
on Twitter just petting animals a show
but this fool must be balling his [ __ ]
but either way first of all his teeth
look ridiculous ever have you noticed
that every time it's his teeth fake
because yet his teeth look [ __ ]
stupid every time brother Nate you know
I [ __ ] love you though my bed I love
it but your teeth look dumb as [ __ ] I
tweeted about about two okay every time
someone comes into money the first thing
they fix is their teeth have you noticed
that the cash me outside girl now has
cheek lays in her mouth - that's right
her teeth look [ __ ] ridiculous
Harold her teeth look like the [ __ ]
Acme cartel [ __ ] that shadows around
with the [ __ ] little spin thing on it
do you remember when Ross got his teeth
bleached yeah that's exactly what it is
like his teeth are [ __ ] fake because
I saw his teeth I'm like yo man nobody's
no human teeth looks like that mmm no
what the [ __ ] there's - look it's
because when they have like a social
media following these dentists will
reach out and be like oh let me do your
teeth for you like oh [ __ ] bet you know
but then they don't look up like hey
this is how real human teeth look like
yes
like you ate a bag of cheese and glued
it on there you know look we have a
friend too that has fake teeth but it's
because he did a he was a stunt dude for
the Universal Studios Oh Yoshi Yoshi
Yoshi he had a get veneers in the front
because he did a front flip in smash
this piece which is a very Yoshi thing
to do
yeah I mean his was but he his veneers
are great hmm you know I mean like I
would have never known that they were
fake they look wonderful
and that's it's funny because my dentist
I developed a really good friendship
with my dentist and whenever I see like
[ __ ] up teeth I send it to him and we
just laugh about it there's toilet bowl
teeth toilet bowl white so what how did
that [ __ ] start coming about like who's
the first person that got the Ross teeth
a lot of the I've seen Instagram makeup
artists do that before like the first
time I ever saw or heard about veneers
was when I used to watch America's Top
Model and like they there would be girls
with like really really [ __ ] up teeth
no I guess like aesthetically from a
model perspective like they it's what
they wanted but their teeth were tore up
like a [ __ ] and they would they
would literally reconstruct their whole
mouth and they would heal in two weeks
and their teeth were just like perfect
mm-hmm it was [ __ ] crazy and that's
why I heard about veneers for the first
time but they theirs look good though it
looks like normal teeth yeah I think
that's a good dentist there are some
people out there just look insane it
looks like some Chinese discount as
teeth dude like what the [ __ ] are they
thinking it was a horse galloping yeah
how does like that dude make money
though I don't know I
because I don't see him do brand deals I
don't know I don't well I said I'll
follow on instant I know I just I love
him on Twitter dude that is [ __ ]
funny yeah yes I know yeah now we gotta
research him cuz I want to know too cuz
he's making so much money off of this
and yes - yeah he's linked up with those
two other funny guys dope Island and
Demetrius Harmon I don't know they make
these funny videos but yeah he teamed up
with them and it's just like he's
everywhere now oh and he's petting and
he's like petting exotic animals in like
Arab Prince's palaces and [ __ ] now I
should say where does he live to where
there's so much [ __ ] deer no idea cuz
I thought he was Mexican I was like damn
Mexican people [ __ ] with deers like that
he was black and then he found out he
was Mexican
also he is Mexican right yeah oh I don't
know Mexico yeah yeah yeah you see here
oh dude that's all I've ever won in life
the pet animals the Internet so what did
he say on his tweet that got him
canceled Oh cancel what he's still doing
well right yeah I think he dropped like
the n-word you know and people were
trying to come after him for that but
then he was like twelve years old at the
time he's a really young kid you know
I'd have tweeted about that I think it
was about him yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's like I'm like I'm not I'm guilty of
that too you like your canceled whatever
you know but there's like four more like
you know what tense stuff I guess I feel
like to a certain extent like once you
tweet something out and if you're like
after it passes like seven years mm-hmm
and let it go like tweets to like back
in the day I think people literally just
said whatever they could and want it
because there wasn't any clout to be no
you know what I mean it was just like
people would use it like Facebook
updates they would use it to just
[ __ ] vent like a [ __ ] right and
mind you too like I I do understand when
I read like a lot of like racial
epithets it makes you know it's a
representation of who this person is but
when I see a young kid like who was like
12 years old like he's talking like one
of those [ __ ] Xbox [ __ ] halo kids
you know I mean and I'm like he was 12
he was probably influenced by his bunch
of stupid ass [ __ ] friends let's give
that a pass you know cuz he's not saying
it now and it doesn't represent who he
is now as a person so how can you drag
somebody for that [ __ ] yeah I'm looking
a little tired of this whole you know
people pointing fingers at everybody
else acting like they're [ __ ] perfect
I'm sick of that [ __ ] dude like who the
[ __ ] are you [ __ ] I want to dig in your
past and see what buttholes you live
tweet about that recently about how
people always worry about like oh he's
not successful or what was it oh I just
been seeing it a lot where like I mean
obviously I've gotten these comments too
but I'm you know I'm on other people's
like YouTube pages of [ __ ] and there's
like these comedians who mind you like I
don't find [ __ ] funny either right
but I'm not gonna sit there and question
why they're successful right cuz just
because right just because you don't
find them funny doesn't mean that there
isn't an audience that finds them funny
there's a reason why they have a million
[ __ ] followers or ten million or
whatever but there's people out there
who I see consistently that'll write a
comment or say something like this and
it's not just comments there's people in
general like I hear this type of gossip
all the time they go oh I don't get it
I don't [ __ ] get it why like I don't
get it like how are they fallen so much
I don't know [ __ ] why don't you work as
hard and then see what's up you [ __ ]
know talentless broke-ass [ __ ] exactly
and it's fail it's really interesting
they'll say that one that the proof is
right in front of them yeah like this
number that says 1 million followers is
right in front of your stupid faces like
oh get it who follows him like yeah and
people support them and people get
something out of them villain well I
don't get it who cares if you don't
[ __ ] get it you know who are you I've
had people come into my stream and
they're like I don't get it why do you
watch her play games so stupid but that
same person has like a Chicago Bulls
Jersey on their profile like why do you
watch someone play basketball it's
literally the same exact thing yeah we
just can't figure it out it's weird you
know and I guess like why what I wonder
when people say these type of things
tonight and I hear this from the people
that say this the most by the way to me
are people who either hate something
about themselves they don't see success
in their life so they have to drag
somebody down to where they are in order
to feel good about themselves right so
you people even have friends like this
where how much have you've experienced
this but I'm like I cut these people out
a while ago but the moment you start
succeeding past some of your friends
like in their eyes they start to hate
you a little bit yes like you start
doing well in their life then all of a
sudden all this other [ __ ] negative [ __ ]
they've never said about you starts to
come out it's like well what's going on
and in my opinion what's happening is
that there are a lot of people out there
that want you to be where they're at and
if you're not where they're at then
you're not their friend yeah I [ __ ]
hate that [ __ ] they don't want you there
so that you feel better about themselves
they don't want someone doing better
than them it's because I think it's
cause like you guys are coming from the
same group of friends like well if he's
making a how come I'm not yeah that's I
guess it's like instead of taking that
time to self-reflect
you're just hating I hate that word
actually you're just putting negative
energy in this you have one yeah dude I
had a so when when I when I moved to LA
there was somebody that yes you were
that's when she got her fresh titties -
I didn't even know flat-chested Gina oh
that's true I didn't know that's I had
no [ __ ] clue you met me
like oh yeah like two three months after
I got them done I remember because you
taught me so much about boobs and that's
why all these [ __ ] was how do you know
so much about fake boobs because of this
girl she told me so much about fake
boobs so when she first got her her
Tatas right she had to slip a slip sleep
45 degrees 45 degrees because if not
because you had to let it drop right
because if not it would looks it was
stay up and I'll [ __ ] we're like
those porn boobies yeah and then you had
to break up the scar tissue and massage
them a squeeze pops it's weird
what cuz scar tissue it's it's called an
encapsulation it can scar around the
implant so hard that it pushes the
implant forward and all you see is just
a round implant under the skin so you go
in there and the doctor has to this is
it happens to some people not everyone
yeah the doctors go in there and he has
to manually with his hands rub out the
scar tissue and you like it pops the
scar tissue and breaks it and I heard
it's like the most painful thing in the
world did you have to do that holy
[ __ ] [ __ ] dude dude there are some
bad titties though I have seen some
terrible titties in my life so Tim and I
hey you know what this girl is a very
sweet girl and you know terrible titties
is very subjective okay but we were we
were shooting assent foods and this girl
came up very high-pitched voice and then
oh my god right and she came up and she
hugged me and it felt like too [ __ ]
round cement balls pressing against my
stomach like oh what the [ __ ]
and it was just like this huge tip yeah
she had to be like five foot three maybe
like a hundred pounds and she decided to
get like these these oh yeah I mean
turns out she's like a little amateur
porn oh that's okay make sense that
makes sense
I only found out because one of my
friends pays for her cam girl [ __ ] oh
wow you know dude because I like her
all my friends are like that no I'm
gonna [ __ ] it who cares yeah they openly
watch porn I don't think anybody yeah
it's always weird when a guy says
they've never watched porn before I was
like if you've said that that means you
watch the sickest [ __ ] you [ __ ] yeah
yeah it gets weird when people are girls
say I don't like it when man watch porn
or like people get insulted at their men
while they're watching porn with you
whether you like it or not if they're
not watching it in front of you they're
them
she's like I'm with him 24/7 not when
you're in the bathroom when he's taking
a [ __ ] in the shower yep
I guarantee you he's not taking a [ __ ]
the whole time he's getting a boner and
he's waiting for it to relax cause he's
watching porn because you won't let him
watch that [ __ ] no one watches porn
there's nothing wrong with that I don't
watch porn as much as I used to them me
neither like it's not um I don't know
why it's not as exciting as it used to
be maybe it's because it's very
redundant mm-hmm and I feel like um like
the the days of those like really well
maybe I just don't research or look into
a lot of things and I don't pay for porn
so like like I don't know why like I've
seen some that are really pretty but
then there's like they think there's so
anybody could be a [ __ ] porn star I
think oh yeah anyone can I think that
the new porn star looked though I like a
lot more than the old one the older one
was like well too much might gonna make
a huge titties now it's more like it's
more chill now like yeah like college
cute girl down like that I like that
more actually I saw um I don't I don't
remember porn stars names but there was
um she was like cheque or something like
that a lot of like cheque women like
like Eastern European women their
[ __ ] ideas [ __ ] dude yeah and I'm
just looking at that I'm like you could
do so much more
I'm like you could do so much more what
are you doing to me porn you could be an
actress yeah sometimes right yeah like
Dan you could oh my god yes yeah because
if you could pretend that [ __ ] ten
inch [ __ ] feels really great I'm pretty
sure you could be a great actress oh my
god yeah wait they watched the porn and
the actress is actually really good no I
think it was to meet sweetie he's like a
salt wheat recently all right I saw a
porn recently and the girl is so good at
I think that instead of getting hard I
want to see like if she can get signed
or something
oh my god that's so [ __ ] weird ready
what hmm you're you're doing um twitch
right now a lot no I'm actually doing
Facebook now so I used to be on twitch i
streamed on twitch for like maybe 2 or 3
months can you explain to me what what
twitch is I don't know what twitches I
don't know how online gaming works I
don't know anything about this world I
just know it's it's big it's super
intricate and everybody's hopping on
this ship I just don't know what it is
and how it works yeah so gaming has
become a huge thing yeah like at this
point ginormous yeah but now it's still
kind of in its infancy so there's
everybody realizes that now I'm gonna
try to hop on while it's still growing
because I'm sure you've seen like those
gaming competitions where it looks it's
like full-on arenas it looks like yeah
my brother yeah it's like super until a
street fighter soo so he always watches
like I always see him on his phone
watching other people play games
yeah and it's which is basically a
platform started off I think it's it was
Justin TV mm-hmm and people go on there
and it used to be just video game
streaming right people would watch you
sit and play video games yeah see what
you're seeing on your screen and you're
like this little in the little corner
and they're watching you yeah yeah yeah
you entertain but it expanded to
something so much more now you can
literally livestream anything you can
live stream this people can talk to you
like you can roll so I could like twitch
stream this this podcast exactly this
there's a whole entire section for
podcasts there's one section called just
chatting where you literally just go
about your day it's called IRL streaming
in real life and people walk around do
their thing while streaming on their
phone people travel and stream on their
phone and they get like tons of viewers
right and on the back end oh you were
doing that before right like we were
like at a JK thing and I said you were
streaming on your phone that [ __ ] was
[ __ ] wild yeah and then people you
know you'd like you have a live chat you
can talk to people you can answer
questions whatever and how on the
backend how are you making money off of
that is people pay for subscriptions
yeah so for every sub that you get you
get like a percentage twitch takes a
percentage but they also can donate to
you and
donations which takes it's like uh it'll
be like like a live patreon then yeah
pretty much yeah okay and so you know
you said that you play games or you'd
like you choose to do it everyone I've
seen all kinds of streams from like
painting streams to drawing streams to
music streams the singing streams to
like people DJing [ __ ] DJ yeah they're
straight up DJ streams there's girls
let's just though Darren they sing they
take song requests you know the video
games is a huge thing and I was on
Twitch for a few months and then
Facebook approached me and they're like
hey we wanted to sign you to like our
pilot program and they were only
choosing a few people damn Facebook
y'all be still in everything probably
doing it better too they're they're
going yeah insanely and they chose a few
people so we're part of the pilot
program basically we help them and give
them feedback on you know what we don't
like about the streaming program what we
do like and we have direct contact to
the developers so I've been with them
since about May and it's been amazing
dude like it's I've been really happy
with them what's what's the biggest
difference between twitch and then the
Facebook so Facebook didn't start off as
a gaming platform yeah so a lot of
people don't realize that Facebook has a
live streaming
you know the platform with for gamers
and stuff like that so right now it's
Facebook it's like 45 year old moms
sharing weird memes you know and nothing
yeah yeah so it's taken them a while
longer to grow their gaming audience and
is it because the Facebook audience is
older wait no I think a lot of older
people play games though yeah a lot of
it right I would say it's a little bit
older though yeah like every one of
their moms on Facebook you know yeah
literally their moms [ __ ]
embarrassing and and they're still
working on their you while I like
everything like they they don't have as
many future it features as twitch that
features like there's plugins and twitch
where people can order you food and send
it to your house anonymous Larry they
won't get your address like they've
partnered up with grub hub you know like
little things like that uh-huh
Facebook can't do that yet but from what
I've seen since I've been with them in
May they've been adding so many new
features that's starting to get there
you know so now people are even though
like we for instance we're getting paid
you know to do this like we're part of
their beta testing the team pretty much
yeah but now people are signing up
because they want to be one of the few
first people like one of the first
people to be on Facebook because what
part of the game even on YouTube if you
got in early then you grow faster than
everyone else you know because you're
coming from the ground up exactly so now
people are hopping over to Facebook also
what the [ __ ]
so twitch is still the the thing on top
though right and it's twitch an app
which is also in Apia you can watch on
mobile down to ok and so like let's say
so it would like there to be like
notifications for when this person is
like streaming and you would get it then
you could tune in whenever you want so
it's almost like like consistent live
like TV programming people then every
day and I keep on telling Joe and you or
I keep on telling Joe especially to
start twitch streaming cuz that's live
streaming is the new thing I didn't
understand it when I was with machinima
on YouTube
yeah because back then was just like oh
you know gaming videos and stuff and
that's what we knew and then the live
streaming portion starts to take over
and they started cutting people out of
the videos and I didn't understand it
yeah right now it's just like it's
become this huge thing and I'm trying to
like encourage everyone to like start
going into live streaming yeah if life's
a means fun for me I'll definitely do it
like all it takes is for me to spark an
interest in something right so like I
see how lucrative a lot of things are
but like the that can't be a basis for
why I I could not not why I want to
start it but why how I can continue to
do so like I just don't want to start it
and then like quit yeah you know I mean
because I that's like that's like my
ongoing theme like I always start
something it does really well that I'm
like over it move on
over it that I'm done you know what I
mean yeah I don't want that to be that
for streaming to especially if I gain a
following and then I just bounce and
bail on people yeah that's what I was
afraid of too cuz you know how I am I
every started my youtube channel like 12
times down ya know and I just couldn't
do it I like twitch because I don't have
to bother other people you know I don't
need to have a cameraman an editor or
anything like that I just pop up and I
stream and then once I turn my stream
off I'm done you know and then I get to
interact with people all the time it's
it's just a lot less work for me and a
lot more fun because I'm doing what I
love which is video games but
now with Facebook I actually have to
only stream video games so I'm getting a
little bit like what is it like cabin
fever yeah just kind of confined into
one thing yeah yeah yeah I haven't
traveled much so I got I got approached
by it wasn't I think it was I forgot I
don't remember the company name but I
think it got bought out into something
bigger mm-hmm but at the time they
offered me to do live streaming with
them but the thing I didn't like that
they were telling me to do at the time
because number one I don't have like a
set schedule right so like auditions but
everything's come in I can't do it at
specific times and they weren't very
flexible on it but they were telling me
I would have a stream like four times a
week and two hours at a time and I'm
like okay well and it has to be a
certain set times I'm like I can't I
can't do that like that's impossible for
me like I know for a lot people like oh
it's only like [ __ ] eight hours of
work I'm like true and it's not you know
it's not like hard work either if you
enjoy it it's fun but if you don't enjoy
then it is hard work
two hours exactly interacting and trying
to talk to somebody or like you know it
was just very odd for me and then it
just got to the point where they you
know they offered me a decent amount of
money but I couldn't commit to the the
time restraint was so [ __ ] hard and
then after I do two hours of talking I
would I still have to do 14 hours of
talking on JK news my brain would
explode which is so funny because that
that was still opposite with me for
YouTube because for YouTube it was just
it was always like the stress of I gotta
upload a video a week you know yeah this
would what streaming I can can I just
make my own schedule and just do
whatever the hell I want see I would
have liked that they let me choose my
own schedule a let's say I missed it
right but okay well we'll all get those
hours done on a different day but I
didn't have that flexibility so I think
like in the when it when things are
betta people are very strict about [ __ ]
nude which I didn't never understood
because remember back in the day when
YouTube first started and when social
media started people didn't understand
what this space was especially when it
came to brand deals
so like when brands would come in they
would say stuff like this they go okay
well we this is the product that we want
to sell but here's the script and this
is how we want you to say and you know
and I couldn't get them to understand
like listen that's the worst idea on
earth this this isn't like a commercial
alright it's not organic at all like
when you when you start a social media
media following there's there's it's a
different
type of energy it's not you can't just
pedal a product to somebody and if you
do do advertisements you have to
understand that there's a relationship
that we've curated with this audience
for about whatever seven eight ten
[ __ ] years you know so you put out a
product that number one you don't
believe in and it's [ __ ]
people people sense that there's
backlash behind it yeah and they would
tell us okay well this is how you're
supposed to it's like how would you know
you don't know my audience exactly you
don't know what they like yeah yo so
there was um so Joe and Bart actually
originally there was a time that I'm not
sure they might have told the story I
think they did on JK news but just to
tell the story again
Bart and Joe actually auditioned to be
in a reboot of in living color oh wow
yeah so they they went into the audition
they did what they had to do they
[ __ ] smash the audition and they got
the role okay they were supposed to be
cast members of in living color yeah and
good thing they didn't choose cuz never
went went on-air a [ __ ] got cancelled
before he even came out but they were
guaranteed a certain amount of money and
it was a good amount of money at the
time because they were [ __ ] broke we
were all broken yeah and but they the
reason why they decided not to there was
a couple of reasons so the first reason
was that when they decided to sign on
they say cool we're gonna sign you too
this is the amount of money that you're
gonna get or whatever or what was told
to me and they go but you have to cancel
your YouTube oh no really
yeah because they didn't understand the
power of social media and that you could
use the social you get to leverage your
[ __ ] show exactly which people do a
lot now they almost write it in the
contract now is like oh if you're on
their show then you have to do this this
this and this what year was this one was
this this was like probably six this is
before we did JK news oh that's why they
didn't understand like seven years early
yeah six or seven years ago and they
were trying to strong-arm a lot of us to
if we did this we would have to delete
out of YouTube yeah it happened all the
[ __ ] time
and we would try to explain to these
[ __ ] like listen that's a
stupid stupid idea you should be using
us to leverage your show and they didn't
do that maybe they just didn't want to
[ __ ] do it they thought it was the
dumbest [ __ ] idea on earth and so I I
worked with um so I worked uh I won't
say the company name but either way it
was it was it was a television show
and they wanted to promote this one guys
show and at this time they didn't know
what the [ __ ] they were doing at all
whatsoever right yeah and they would
arguably be [ __ ] condescending
towards me and a lot of like young
creators at the time because they just
thought that we were trash youtubers
nobody took youtuber seriously back then
hey nobody took any of us seriously they
thought we were just a bunch of [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] they didn't understand that
number one like you're you're having me
promote a show about a guy who's doing
this comedy show [ __ ] I've been doing
stand-up since I was 16 like don't
[ __ ] tell me what's funny you know
but they don't care did you see me and
labeled me as a youtuber and so like
literally this this rep had me go in and
I was supposed to interview this person
and then put that interview like on my
channel or whatever and they were
supposed to send me a package of
everything with this guy's about so I
could formulate these questions so I go
in and they go oh you don't need any of
that stuff you could just go in and go
in and and me and it was just me staring
at him with nothing to say and I was
like okay what are we supposed to do he
goes well you were supposed to be so
prepared we sent you a package I was
like no nobody sent me a [ __ ] packet
I asked they said they were gonna send
me like this whole thing on an email all
this information they didn't send
[ __ ] [ __ ] I come outside I'm [ __ ]
pissed yeah and I'm like you know where
was this stuff I'm like oh I'm sorry I
completely messed up blah blah blah blah
right this person was like the
coordinator of the producer right
later on I hear later I get an email
saying I was super unprofessional I was
unprepared I didn't know what I was
doing
well I would be so mad I was [ __ ]
infuriated yeah and that person uh you
know I get it
they were looking out for their [ __ ]
job but they dragged me through the mud
and made them look at as if I was
irresponsible yeah I was asking where
the [ __ ] is the stuff so I can do this
properly it's not my [ __ ] first rodeo
dude like let you know and this is just
the type of [ __ ] that we had to deal
with on a regular [ __ ] basis and we
couldn't go ahead and you know at this
time like outing people wasn't a great
idea because you know TV was such a
scary [ __ ] monster right but now that
we're on our own platform we can do what
we want and we set these [ __ ] rules
right oh hated those are [ __ ]
experiences I can oh my god I cannot
imagine that I mean you have like it's
so interesting too because I feel like
like your your your audiences is is is
weird because girls have a very
interesting audience that I really enjoy
is because
I feel girls have two things right
number one girls either want to be you
all guys want to [ __ ] you mm and it's
like the most powerful thing I've ever
seen in my life it's the strangest thing
the role because like I'll get messages
like oh my god I look up to you in Volvo
I'm like really know what I did today I
have not washed my face in three days
and it's like the sweetest thing I love
those messages so much but it is strange
like it's a mixture of I I look up to
you and hey girl send me your feet you
know I just can't still can't believe
you guys don't send pictures of your
feet I just talked to Julia about this
[ __ ] - I was like dude just send
them your [ __ ] feet and get some
money off of it no see the thing is you
assume that people aren't offering money
if someone were to offer me money
absolutely like I'm there but no this is
just I like you seen my facebook
sometimes like I upload like the
screenshots of the strangers messages I
get yeah and the one time that I cited
you know what fine let's see where this
goes this guy's like send me send me
pictures your feet I'm like fine 100
bucks each no response I'm like damn eat
see this is why Oh see that's what it is
dude they're just [ __ ] weird but they
don't or their poor weird yeah like I
can't like come on now well would you do
that type of [ __ ] though weird that
what's it what's that thing we're um
what is that [ __ ] funny noise I don't
know I hear it yeah oh is it my phone I
think I [ __ ] up well maybe I should
put it on airplane apart I know yeah
that's my phone anyway sorry guys I'm
[ __ ] up but anyways like um would you
do that thing where um what's it when
some um when a [ __ ] rich guy pays uh
like a like a hot girl to like [ __ ]
berate them and [ __ ] oh that what does
that call bit that [ __ ] like domination
it's like a domination ship but then it
would be like oh hey pigs yeah this is
what they're called financial domination
pigs is what they're calling financial
domination
I know people who do it but personally I
can't because it would be like
so okay so I wish I'm not I can't okay
well okay hold on a second hold on is
that you know we're gonna okay my name
is Richard poor yes key port yes key
port guess key okay it means Richard the
porky my name is Richard poor Jesse okay
I am 400 pounds mm-hmm hairy chest
smelly mmm-hmm however I'm paying you to
put a rope around my neck and then take
the tip of the rope put some [ __ ]
metal beads on it and then slap my
[ __ ] and I'll give you [ __ ] ten
thousand dollars an hour for this [ __ ] I
got a rope in my car [ __ ] you want it
let's go don't these girls get like a
weird insane amount of money probably
not that much though pretty good money
oh so so there's a difference so that's
like dominatrix stuff right and there's
but then there's what I'm talking about
is financial domination which I had a
girl who did that right yeah and I'm
like how the [ __ ] do you even like I
can't I can't breathe I can't be around
people that I don't want to be you know
I can't fake it
yeah and the thing is they're so good at
it dude and you have to be creative
that's the thing cuz I told I asked him
like how the [ __ ] like what do you say
to them and she said oh like one of my
examples is I want you to wire a $5,000
to me in tens or I mean oh yeah uh I'm
sorry you have to bring a bag of money
over to me five thousand dollars only
intense because I am a 10 out of 10 and
that shit's so creative I can't do that
that's like the dialogue that they like
exactly I'm just like you know you gotta
[ __ ] get in the zone
yeah you have to play that part and I I
don't have a passion in that so I can't
you know you just gotta walk in and just
[ __ ] berate them dude the only thing
I can I can always that's all [ __ ]
fat smelly [ __ ] tow and only the left
one is you don't deserve the big tone
you [ __ ] fat Richard [ __ ] you know
why your name is Richard just cuz you're
a dick and your dick is so [ __ ] small
you did great oh dude let me dominate
the [ __ ] out of some I'm not sure if you
get off on it but I would talk [ __ ] to
you for [ __ ] days you would be so
great at it and they go they go real
life like if you don't pay me money I
will tell your wife what you're doing
right now
give me your credit card I don't know
how to do that you know like I like I
can't talk to someone like that like the
physical domination I'm good but then
also you have to understand that I can't
do this personally because when it comes
to sex and whatever I'm submissive so I
don't like I I wouldn't even know how to
feel that role
oh yeah which is really weird because
people don't like they don't expect that
out of me but I am submissive in my
relationships like when it comes to sex
so if someone were to ask me like hey
dominate me I'll just be like oh cuz
you're the other way around
that's not something that you could
really play well mm-hmm just gotta give
catches take some acting classes you
know I know dude the girl that I always
tell you about the one that I've known
her for [ __ ] forever she's a she's a
very high-end escort oh yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah she posted the funniest [ __ ]
she posted a picture of a conversation
between her and her sister and it was a
picture of a pair of Christian Louboutin
shoes the one time that I saw it was
about like I want to say like $1,800 god
yeah and she told her sister hey when I
come home for Christmas try this on and
the caption for the photo said these
shoes don't fit me so I'm letting my
sister try it on I had to [ __ ] a guy in
the ass with the remote control for this
and I'll be damned if these things go to
waste
oh my god yeah and I've gotten into like
very long in-depth conversations with
her about being an escort like how like
what what do you do and she said you
know the weird thing is whenever people
think of sex work they think oh I gotta
[ __ ] these ugly dudes that I don't want
to be around but she's not [ __ ] them
she's not she's 1 she's not [ __ ] them
all the time cuz all I really wants
companionship and - she gets to choose
who her clients are
exactly and she showed me photos of some
her clients these dudes are handsome
rich dudes like in their 30s that look
like male models dude my majors so what
is it is it's a mental thing then like
they want to be the [ __ ] maybe cuz
they're like [ __ ] top dog all the
time exactly like they like being they
want to be on the other you [ __ ] sick
[ __ ] or like she lives in San Francisco
like one of the most expensive [ __ ]
places in the world oh yeah yeah yeah
and she lives right near the of
the finance tower like something a
really rich ball and play yeah and these
guys are so rich that they they're so
busy yeah they can't find time to find
female companionship to date or whatever
so sometimes they just want to get off
and she said you know 80% of the time I
don't even [ __ ] them
I like there's this one guy that pays
her thousands just to chill smoke weed
eat pizza and watch Game of Thrones with
him that sounds nice that was so
pleasant well what kind of [ __ ]
remote was that guy [ __ ] with I hope
it was like a Roku remote and not like
big ones I hope it wasn't a Comcast
cable box remote that [ __ ] all the
channels are changing superfast skin
because it's rubber do they meet in a in
a in a hotel or their house apparently
what they do is and I've read about this
I saw some red it's who she would sit at
a bar at like the Four Seasons or the
Ritz Carlton very expensive places she
would sit there in a bar have a few
drinks read her book whatever and that's
how she finds her clients they they just
come up to her and they're just like you
you stick [ __ ] remote know-how the
start of that conversation that's what I
wonder you know I mean so you go to the
Ritz Carlton and then what makes them
think that she is the person to [ __ ] him
in the ass
Yeah right with a balloon I don't know I
I think it's how she presents herself
like cuz she's she's not a bad-looking
girl dude she's pretty her body is tight
like she looks amazing she's older than
me she's probably somewhere in her like
mid-30s or so and she looks great like
and I think it's just how she presents
herself she's very open like this girl
is [ __ ] wild like I've known her
wooden back when I was go-go dancing
when she was like before the sex work
you know and this [ __ ] is wild she
parties you know and I think this is
really how she presents herself cuz when
I first met her like you can kind of
tell I looked at I was like you are
insane and super fun I love it you know
you don't kill but yeah and she's one of
those people and it's just like him
people open up to her and they can talk
to her very
you know comfortably and freely I have
no idea how the conversation would start
but I think the way she presents herself
I want you to try to be an escort right
now okay okay okay so you're at bar so
just in San Francisco there's jazz music
playing in the background keep it
playing in the background right now
right uh-huh
so you are wearing what if you're an
escort what are you wearing super tight
skirt very expensive heels expensive
designer purse and jewelry all right
mm-hmm you have to look like you have
money because these men will look at you
and be like she has money how does she
have that there's only two three well
three ways she can have that one she's
successful herself to riches husband
three she's an escort oh yeah so you
can't come in there looking all raggedy
and [ __ ] okay well my name is raggedy
Richard Richard now is just pissed I
don't know there's a lot of Richard's I
don't like those Richards I'd like to
though what like so he comes up and he's
just gonna look at you okay so what's
going on you look you want to get a
drink okay with the 13th will you
clearly having that Louie the 76 I don't
know [ __ ] about alcohol let me get the
Louis the 76 for this beautiful lady
here we poured a glug look Oh in the
back I'm pouring that drink we slide it
over your drinking we're chatting it up
blah blah
so where did this conversation go to for
me to assume that you're an escort it
would you would have the initiation yeah
I think so I have no idea how she does
it but I really I really did so what do
you do oh you know just some business
here and there
Oh business what type of business um
[ __ ] yeah you really couldn't be an
escort could you look at you in a fake
situation I don't know I wouldn't like
I'm on the spot fine I'm gonna be the
escort yeah you're gonna be Richard
Richard the [ __ ]
rich rich [ __ ] all right I'm bitching
yeah you're [ __ ] you're bitchin Pryor
Richard Richard Pryor and I'm [ __ ]
Suze this the sex mink I'm by the way
I'm smoking a really long cigarette
there's attached to a gold tip okay yes
I'm doing I'm sure you might watch right
now yeah all right and then from what I
learned from her um what is it
rich men never wear socks oh okay
Richmond dress shoes and no socks okay
that's what's going on right now I'm
over here smoking my long cigarette and
I also smell like [ __ ] juice here we go
so what are you doing here that's the
sound of B uh smoking my bubble pipe but
detective or here we go you come here oh
I don't know do I
I don't know I see you a few times a
week here and I just want to see you
know what do you do here do you work
around here it doesn't look like I work
here you couldn't afford B I can't
afford you
oh that's a really good segue holy [ __ ]
that was BAM look at that oh you're a
good home dude call me Priscilla the
[ __ ] juice dude that's what I'm telling
you right now dude I was born the wrong
sex but what if you did that and he was
like what do you mean I can't afford you
you think I don't make money was like I
don't know why don't you prove it to me
[Music]
I'm trying to get [ __ ] tonight son out
of all these years between David and
Geena everyone thought Gina was the hole
but David was a clear better ho dude I'm
a [ __ ] ho you know what the weird
thing is from like comments i've been
getting recently um use always be damn
Gina must be a ho and it actually
shifted now - what - damn Gina when are
you gonna get married oh really
yeah which is really weird I'm like wait
I thought it was a whole like two weeks
ago
Oh the internet is [ __ ] fake how
strange is that right the internet is
[ __ ] fake what isn't Gina's [ __ ]
so many guys - when's Gina getting
married I think it's because like
everyone like Gio and Tiffany
we're getting married yeah and they
think me and Geo and whatever and Tiff's
and Barton them are the same age oh
that's right young yeah they're a lot
older than us yeah they're a lot older
than us and then people like so when are
you getting married I'm like dude I'm
still in my 20s yeah I'm still home dude
persecuted I'm gonna be I'm 31 next this
year we met when you were home uh [ __ ] I
don't [ __ ] know you moved down here
2011 alright
yeah and I think I was like 24 23 yeah
yeah we were babies yeah you were a
[ __ ] child
you don't really changed much at all do
I think when we the one thing that I
clearly remember about you though so
[ __ ] funny is that I wanted to go
hiking at the Hollywood sign thing and I
don't think you ever went either and we
went hiking together this was one of our
like our third time hanging out third
time hanging out and just to tell you
there's a funny story about how I'm even
connected to her this is the [ __ ]
funniest thing but we were hiking and I
remember because she just got her
titties in didn't feel back great at the
time but she's just like oh my god so
much like going in my big ass titties I
can't I can't I can't handle this [ __ ]
she was dying up there mind you this is
like I was really fat too and I just
looked at her Allah dude this [ __ ] is
out of [ __ ] yeah 100% yeah you were
killing me dude yeah you were out of
shape it got up to the very top and I
was actively dying yeah throughout the
whole thing we're with same baby yeah
you a name and I remember looking at
Dave like how the [ __ ] is this big [ __ ]
moving so fast dude I'm agile have you
ever seen a bear go after a [ __ ] pot
of honey Winnie the Pooh [ __ ]
but I was like they're our third time
hanging out right you know this is when
I lived in Orange County Dave and I met
when the the UCLA video yeah the usual
I forgot how we got connected I think it
was because of your brother yeah via
Facebook that's right so he told me that
there was he has a half-sister that
lived on semester
yes that sister that lives out in LA and
that she's super funny whatever you guys
shouldn't you guys be great friends I
was like alright cool and the only
reason why I know her brother is because
I knew I knew him as aids boy and he's
not I know that sounds [ __ ] bad it's
not because he has AIDS because this
dude was a hypochondriac so we used to
so he's a year younger than me and we
used to go to the same junior high
together
James runner middle school shot the
James runner in middle school that place
is trashed
it's [ __ ] ghetto better warm that up
those Sox backs on sir
but I met her brother in junior high he
was a year younger than me I didn't
actually know his name
I just knew him as AIDS boy a couple of
my friends knew him as aids boy because
he didn't he never wanted to share his
drinks and I forgot who his friend was
that wanted to share his fruit punch
Fruitopia and I remember you it was that
it was the red fruit topia and then he
if we had like a presentation in school
about like venereal diseases and he got
freaked the [ __ ] out it was during that
time and so his friend wanted a drink of
his Fruitopia
it was at it was at the bus stop where
we got off and he was like nah cuz I
can't share this with you he goes no
I'll just waterfall it kids with these
waterfalls do so they don't put lips on
it and they're like no bull just boy he
goes nah I can't get AIDS
I was so shocked I was like what the
[ __ ] did he just say he does not I can't
get aids aids boy do you remember our
first phone call no our first phone call
lasted like almost two hours long
because so hey like David I can't when I
move to LA you know let's link up
whatever you whatever and like cuz we
were like we were laughing so hard
messing messaging each other on Facebook
yeah and um I was like yeah let's link
up I gave him my number
completely forgot that I gave my number
by the way and then one day I get a
phone call and I pick it up I'm like
hello who's this and he goes David I'm
like who the [ __ ] is David like and then
like I and then I thought in my mind I
was like oh it's a David from whatever
else right and I went on like for like
30 seconds just like random [ __ ] about a
different David and then he goes wrong I
this
David so and I was like oh yeah that's
right we had like the longest
conversation like and I wanna have two
hours yeah and we were just [ __ ] on
each other what the whole entire time
just talking the mad [ __ ] yeah and then
I specifically remember saying that if
you were on fire and I had a glass of
water I would drink it and she was she
was literally one of my first friends in
LA and I think like the transitioning
part to LA like I didn't like number one
even till this day I don't have a lot of
friends here like I literally talked to
the same [ __ ] people like it's like
you Bart
Joe geo mm-hmm
like who asked people I live with yeah
like I'm very just like I always keep my
circle really tight same right and if
there's somebody new that came into my
life that I that I like it's it's not
very common yeah yeah I mean just
because like I mean why like once you
reach a certain age it's like let's make
more friends as like oh my [ __ ] my
friend should cap his fields yeah like
I'm very friend I'm not saying like I
don't make great acquaintances I'm just
saying I don't make a lot of like close
tight friends anymore not because I
don't want to just like maybe is I don't
want I just don't care enough yeah even
with tight friends like I don't even see
them that much like I have my my friends
I've known for like 12 years yeah
literally lives like maybe two miles
away from me I'll see her like once a
month it's not right you know that's how
close friends do it did exactly that's
how adults do it now I was just I can't
I can't be [ __ ] to go out and just
find more friends I still I still talk
to my best friend on the phone like yeah
at least once a week you know all these
years yeah he's just he's just the
doctor version of me yeah like the one
thing that I remember about him and I
think I started till this day he's still
somewhere in was it like Ethiopia
helping people he was god dammit he was
last time he told me oh yeah so he went
to the Peace Corps for two years and he
was in Ecuador Ecuador yeah yeah so he
was an Ecuadorian this guy was losing
his [ __ ] mind over there I'm talking
about he sent me snail mail this dude
like dude it's [ __ ] hilarious
have it somewhere it's like in a box
where I locked it up I just don't want
to see it yeah he was so he was losing
his mind so much while he was an Ecuador
this [ __ ] wrote me a potential
script okay this is [ __ ] right his
writing is terrible by the way and she
writes a script on like ghetto ass
binder paper and he crumpled that [ __ ]
up those are than the [ __ ] note and
snail mail that all across from Ecuador
all the way to here for me to read it
till this day I have it read I refuse
the reason why I haven't read it is
because I feel if I read it I'm not
gonna be his friend anymore
imagine oh like you're sitting on a gold
mine this is the next box office oh if
it is I'm still I bet you he doesn't
know what he wrote and I'll never admit
yup and I'm just gonna buy him a Lambo
and he's not gonna know why I've always
if you wrote the dumb [ __ ] that you'll
do when you're rich Oh 100% like I
already told Dave about this ava is my
manager by the way if I ever become
falling out of my mind everybody that I
hate I'm just gonna slap the [ __ ]
[ __ ] out of them and I'm gonna throw a
wad of cash in their face while you're
helping them no but cuz they're not
gonna do [ __ ]
I must slap them I might do and I don't
[ __ ] ten grand in their face in
Lightroom there's no look at me like
what I'm like what I give you ten right
now [ __ ] take the slap you [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] I would go after my
friends like you I would spend probably
the good like first year or so harassing
my friends as much as possible but
giving back also did you know what I
realized you know that show it was the
the show that blew up Urth Caffe was
that HBO show it was about celebrity it
was an actor that he lived with a bunch
of friends do I sound like all the dudes
but do the guys right and I want to say
the escorts but it's not the S entourage
ROG there you go we're doing this little
escort thing yeah I gotta get her on
your show or something or stories it'll
be all three of us I want to hear her
[ __ ] so is Entourage and I started to
realize why and I used to look at the
people around that the main character
has a bunch of [ __ ] losers like
turtle and all this other [ __ ] and I was
like to look at these [ __ ] losers but
that really losers what they are is that
this guy is so [ __ ] rich he has so
much time on his hands doing [ __ ] if
his friends are working they can't hang
with him he's bored out of his [ __ ]
mind yeah so if you have an unlimited
supply of [ __ ] money why do you want
to be alone yeah why would you be alone
especially when you're young and you're
not married and you don't have kids it's
like okay well I'll just pay for my
friends to be around me so we could just
hang out all day yeah like if you had an
unlimited supply money why the [ __ ] not
exactly it would be so stupid it's it's
and that's what I would do like I would
love to harass my friends and do stupid
[ __ ] to them I would kill for you like
10 grand every time I beat you up I
would love that dude I hope I hope you
just marry the richest [ __ ] ugliest
guy you know what okay so here's a
strange thing that I've been really it's
been really interesting we're gonna get
a little bit deeper here so we are you
and I are about the same age almost like
yeah I was like two years apart
yeah okay so for the last like two three
years or so I was kind of going through
like this weird crossroads right and
it's very strange because I started
talking to other people about it and I
realized it's pretty common as an Asian
female yeah you know before the whole
social media thing whatever uh you're
raised to be a wife the perfect wife I
was raised to cook clean you know
everything was very ladylike right
and we you've heard Asian parents before
like I want my daughter to marry like a
rich doctor yeah you know yeah it's like
that classic old saying yeah yeah
exactly you know marry rich have you you
know be taken care of you know you you
my dad's the same is that you cook after
you cook for him you clean for him and
stuff right oh he's like old fashioned
is funny really fell for like a chola
yeah your dad's a Vietnamese tollable
yeah sir I mean that with the highest
amount of respect your father looks like
he's killed people and he's never cared
about it the man looks like he could
stab me and then he would make me
breakfast the next morning as if he
didn't do it oh yeah and it's funny
because I showed David a Halloween photo
of my dad and his wife they dressed up
as cholos or a cholo naturally fell for
it just it just looked like a regular
Sunday my mom literally said I didn't
have to go shopping for him it was just
in his closet he's like we're gonna
dress I need you get some looks a long
teams of baggy pants closing I thought
we're gonna dress up you know I thought
wait you mean Monday yeah that's my
monday busy but
so my dad you know even though he is
Americanized he speaks English well he's
Mexican cholo for some reason on the
inside yeah he's very old-school you
know like I want you to find a rich
husband but the thing is when with women
growing up in that age they are now like
around my age and you're going through
the internet phase where everyone's like
hashtag boss [ __ ] independent we don't
need no man we do our own thing blah
blah blah yeah yeah so it's very strange
when you're being raised to think one
way and when you grow up
people are making it seem like that way
that you're raised is wrong you know I
mean why would you ever depend on a man
why would you ever blah blah blah why
would you have a man pay for all your
things like that's some weak [ __ ] right
so it's a very interesting crossroads
because when I was young I was like that
is what I want you know like I I want to
be taken care of I love nice things and
then you grow up and people are telling
you that that's wrong but you should
depend on yourself right so for like the
longest time I went through like I dated
Brook boys because I'm like you know
what I'm independent I make good money I
can take care of whatever I can pay for
[ __ ] yeah but then on the inside I'm
like this is not exactly what I want you
know and it's it's become like a weird
finding yourself like and it's guns to
point where I'm like alright you know
what
I'm just didn't go after exactly what I
want and what I want is is for someone
take care of me that's how I was raised
and that's what I want you know yeah
and it always raises the argument of
well that makes you a gold digger that
depends like my thing about gold digging
or how I see it anyways is this it's
like there's always a give-and-take in a
situation right so like for example like
there was this age-old thing where I
think like a lot of people looked at
like being a housewife as not work yeah
right but if you ever maintain a home
it's hard dude it's a lot of [ __ ]
work and then throw kids on that [ __ ]
no kids on top of that [ __ ] though
making meals planning trips doing all
the school stuff that is there's a
finance so if you don't think that's a
job then why the [ __ ] would you ever
hire a 24/7 nanny ven mmm you know so
your arguments kind of thrown out the
[ __ ] window right
so the I consider a gold-digger a girl
who number one just doesn't do [ __ ] you
don't I mean like you literally just
take and there's no give yes
right so let's say that let's see your
thing is you want to be taken care of
right but his knees are that well I
would still like you to number one so
you know support me emotionally be there
for me when I need you show me love and
affection whatever make me a meal every
now and then if you're at home you know
take care of [ __ ] around the house are
you a gold digger then no there's like a
give-and-take in that relationship right
that's all I say people don't seem to
understand that it's like if you if
until this day like if a woman came out
and said I want to date a man who's
successful it makes a lot of money the
first thing that will pop in someone's
head is gold digger not housewife you
know yeah and people don't understand
that it's it's it's very strange so when
I try to explain to them is like no when
I say that I want to date someone that's
successful it means I want my kids to
never have to worry for anything I like
nice things by the way and I want a
solution your love languages gifts
gift-giving and acts of service
okay mm-hmm and and it would give this
one or give this one okay mm-hmm and it
was really weird like like time of
change and self reflection Familia what
do I want like because I was trying to
be what everyone was saying that was
good like you have to be independent not
careful makes you feel like you're being
a bad woman yeah yeah exactly and it
made me feel like it wasn't being true
to myself yeah you know and then I
finally realized when when you reach
this age like you have to be true to
yourself you can't be chasing after [ __ ]
what other people say are you good
anymore and it's gotten to the point
where I'm like all right I'm dating a
rich guy yeah you know and and that's
because one I want to live come clean to
I want my kids to live comfortably too
yeah and so I feel like a lot of girls
out there are still going through that
fight with themselves you know and it's
it's like there's nothing wrong yeah one
thing what you want and also to you know
I've seen arguably a lot of girls who
who have the what was the word I'm
looking for
they say the right things right now but
they don't follow through with what
they're saying they'll be like well I
want to be that I want to be a
successful boss [ __ ] but I don't need a
man mm-hmm
but your actions say otherwise you know
so they want to be a part of that
rhetoric but they're they're not
following through at the same time I
think the for me with the important
thing is what's communicated in the
beginning people have what they want
if is communicating the beginning and
that person is okay with it awesome
then what's then what's the [ __ ]
problem both people are happy right so
what the [ __ ] the big deal so I think
like a lot of the issues like people
were for example there was the there's
that age-old argument so remember when
that photo was going around the internet
about that girl who had surgery what she
looked like before and then the husband
divorced her yes because of how she
looked be prior to the surgery right and
then people were [ __ ] on this guy no
he was they were [ __ ] on him they
were like how [ __ ] dare your marriage
are you guys have kids like how can
looks be the basis of your relationship
but it's like we'll hold on for a second
I understand I completely understand
what people are saying but they have
they don't what they don't understand is
this that guy predicated his affection
to that woman because of how she looked
yeah that's that was it was on the table
there was no deception behind it he
wanted a hot lady to [ __ ] have his
kids and that's what he liked about her
and he came out with some [ __ ] I'm not
sure if this story was true whether it's
true or not the the conversations that
were having after it was that was
happening after it was a little weird
because I didn't understand why people
didn't get why somebody like that could
be upset that he was lied to about
something it's deception
it's deception right whether you have
this this this your moral compass says
that you shouldn't judge somebody based
on their looks
that's your relationship there are
people there are relationships that
survive for many years predicated on
looks I'm not saying it's a good thing
that's not how I function I don't
personally think it's healthy but if
that's what they want let those people
have what they [ __ ] want you can't
tell them that they can't have what they
want that's that's that's what it is
based on your morals and what you like
and what you like it's a very odd thing
for me right so when that story came out
and I think I got a little flak from
this I was like well how can you get mad
at that guy feel like well because he's
just saying I'm with them because I'm
with her because she's pretty well yeah
that's what the foundation was that's
one of them yeah that was one of the big
things obviously that attracted him to
her the first place yeah yeah yeah yeah
that's it's people people don't realize
that what you personally like does not
[ __ ] matter to me yeah people people
will tell me like well money's not
everything well yeah okay to you
yeah
I like my nice things like living in a
nice house you know and if you're okay
with not having that cool I'm not you
know and it comes down to preference and
people don't realize that people have
preferences leave them the [ __ ] alone
about it yeah yeah and and one of my
recent relationships I actually laid it
out and like look this is what I'm
looking for alright I want to be a
housewife while working on my own
business to whatever and I want a
husband that does this this and this and
then he was just like alright cool like
that's that's what I want too let's go
yeah like you don't have time for trying
to figure out this and that whatever
anymore and waste all this time anymore
when you reach a certain age you know
yeah yeah yeah so it's I I feel like
people should stop feeling bad about not
fitting what the society tells you that
you should do nowadays yeah it's it's
hard been like I think it's better that
you you're honest with it and then you
know what you want yeah right because
you know if in your past relationship
people expected something out of you
that you never said that you wanted the
nose probably or was a big issue then
cuz it's like because if that's the case
then then they expected you to be like
on their level of like hustling and
grinding and working 24/7 then they
would probably look at you like you're
[ __ ] lazy like you like what are you
doing with your life but it's like yo
I've never said this what I want I said
I wanted to work hard in the household I
wanted to maintain the household while
you go out and do the work that's what I
wanted so if that was out on the table
it's kind of your fault you you didn't
get a lemon you just [ __ ] got the
wrong car exactly you know it's like I I
think one of the things is well know
there's people there's people that [ __ ]
on theirs there's like two types of
women like that it's uh ones that do
work during the really [ __ ] like they
they they bring something to the table
yeah and there's also women who don't
yeah like they're just they're the rich
housewife that gets drunk on mimosas on
Sunday you know and there's nothing
wrong with both like I can't [ __ ] on any
of those you know if you're the lazy
wife [ __ ] it awesome whatever it's
working for your relationship fine
that's totally okay with its it's it's
gotten to the point of like acceptance
you know you have to accept these people
and their relationship because I has
literally nothing to do with you at all
yeah yeah it's gone apart and I think
just yeah it's just people like to
project what they want out of something
onto other people and you know I think a
lot of us are guilty on that [ __ ] too
it's just it's just yeah it's that
rhetoric in that and that that that
conversation that keeps on happening of
you know girls can have it all like you
can be the successful woman that has
kids that makes her own money paves her
own way is the boss of the house you
don't need a [ __ ] man and you know
when I heard that she'll my - that's a
lot of [ __ ] work man
but you want to do all that [ __ ] but
what about the dude the dude is just
gonna just chill do nothing I guess if
that's what you want yeah you know but I
don't know it's a lot of work I mean as
a housewife you're a nanny a chef an
accountant if you're here you know like
you're doing everything in people when
that when that rhetoric came out and
said like you can be a boss which
whatever they also they failed to also
encourage but you can also be this ya
know it's okay to be this also yeah well
that's kind of cool
let you figure that [ __ ] out that's nice
grow when you learn I know man
I like difficult that's when to know man
that's my [ __ ] problem that's what I
found that about myself I used to think
that I wanted like a very quiet just
sweet girl to kind of counterbalance how
I am as a human being yeah and what'd
you find out once you get old until you
tend to be I could understand why people
say like God guys always end up with
women that are kind of like their mom
right
women same with women too with their dad
right same [ __ ] right it's kind of
[ __ ] weird man it's kind of creepy
cuz my whole life I kind of like chased
the opposite right in terms of long term
relationships like if it was just we're
[ __ ] around it didn't matter who you
were that you were gonna stick around
for a long time and even was I so like
the previous girlfriend that I had
before Muriel she was very agreeable
right so even though like arguably there
are be times where she and I go back and
forth on something and clearly I am
wrong right but just me being a stubborn
human being I don't want to be wrong and
then she'd be like you're probably right
and in my mind I'm like you know say
something but she wouldn't do it yeah
and so I thought that huh maybe I do
want a girl that'll stand up for herself
a little bit that just as
egregious to agree so even when we had
our arguments and even if she was wrong
like I wanted her to express why she
thought she was right just so I could
get to know her yes you know in those
moments when we clash and we don't agree
on things because we are two different
people we're gonna get to know each
other and because of that I felt like in
that relation relationship I got duped
because who she was in the beginning of
the relationship wasn't who she was
towards the end of our relationship and
it's because she just was never honest
she didn't want to just butt heads on
anything so I could never figure her out
so this goofy very fun girl who I
thought I was with wasn't that type of
girl she was actually very just like
subdued very like I'll do whatever you
want nothing I don't like that should do
it like that
like I wanna I want like I always
[ __ ] get irritated at this [ __ ] but I
think I do like combative women yeah I
like girls that you know or I'm like hey
can you leave the toilet seat up and she
goes [ __ ] you I'm like do ya saying that
[ __ ] it's weird like I've grown up to be
exactly like my dad yeah you know and
it's like the strange thing cuz I've
only spent maybe like eight months
within my whole life
we didn't we never lived together and
it's weird but he he and I are the same
in a sense we're very stubborn and we
can't be with people who are like us you
know III can't really be with anyone
who's agreeable all the time either
because it's like I kind of walk all
over you you know I need something to
kind of fight back with me because I
will become a spoiled [ __ ] you know
like I won't be that [ __ ] you knows I
have to have some like you I have to
have someone that fights back I just
need a little bite you know I mean even
even god damn it it's coming down like
I'm a mother [ __ ] dude what is going on
dude yo it's gonna be ready in LA till
[ __ ] Tuesday I love it
I like grass in my backyard now I like
that's right I like rain this is
ridiculous this is like a downpour that
means we can post meet some food I'm not
driving home in this oh we're gonna go
out to eat at this oh we goin somewhere
yeah I'm driving the haha drive trust me
I'll Drive and you I don't know so much
and plus like my car's way sturdier than
yours and I just filled up the [ __ ]
tires with air finally anyways guys so
yeah dude we did an hour and [ __ ]
like
eleven minutes oh wow under this [ __ ]
man passed an hour mark so actually I
forgot to introduce you in the beginning
of the podcast cuz I'm so comfortable
with you
I assume that everybody knows who you
are cuz we've been a [ __ ] duo for
like eight years
but anyways people still ship us after
like eight years I don't know see this
is how stupid we would be a [ __ ]
disaster terrible couple
be hilarious yeah we would be what you
call a sitcom couple yeah just fighting
all the [ __ ] time mmm-hmm very
different I try to take care of nobody
and I'm trying to be poor ready I don't
think you can deal with my brattiness
like I would be able to deal with
Muriel's but just for the people who
don't need everybody knows what the [ __ ]
you are where can they find you what do
you do I stream video games I was
David's counterpart on YouTube for a few
videos like a long time ago hmm and I
know it's few months with my name is
Gina darling which by the way I think
I'm gonna come out with my real last
name soon because I'm sick of tired and
sick and tired of sounding like a
stripper and you know everybody has
taken your your [ __ ] moniker too I
see everybody something darling me yeah
I'm like you [ __ ] unoriginal I'm sick
of it now yeah but my name is Gina
darling I scream on Facebook if you guys
wanna check me out it is facebook.com
slash I heart Gina I stream five days a
week and I accept on Tuesdays and
Thursdays when I have to film with JK I
built that schedule around us so come
and watch me come hang out come and talk
to me we play video games I berate
people Instagram Gina darling as well
Instagram is miss Gina darling mister
okay Gina darling yes we forgot about
them remember guys you guys could check
us out on iTunes we're talking about
podcast [ __ ] like cast box Spotify and a
bunch of other ones I can't remember the
names but if there's an audio platform
for for this stuff yeah we're gonna be
on it but I will see you guys next time
genius brains love you [ __ ]
don't die stay strong and if you don't
watch porn or you say you don't you
clearly do you sick [ __ ] see you guys
next time bye
[Music]